David Frum good to be with you thank you
so much I must say I like the title of
your book very much it seems fitting
that a president who's so brand
conscious and likes to see his name on
hotels and golf courses and steaks would
also get his own brand name regime type
with Trump Agra see so with that in mind
can you define Trump apocrypha and
explain how you came up with this
concept well we are all mesmerized by
Donald Trump's outsized personality and
it's natural to believe that the
personality is the secret to what is
going on
Trump RC which comes from the same root
as democracy an autocracy is a book
about the study of power that's that's
what the suffix means this is the study
of Donald Trump's power how did he get
it how does he maintain it how does he
get away with them so Trump RC is the
system of enabling it's the system in
the White House it's the system between
Trump and Congress
it's the system between Trump and the
media that enable him and create an
audience it's the system that involves
is the Republican donor elite the
traditional elements of the Republican
Party would have succumbed to him and
above all between him and that core
group of his voters within the
Republican Party who enabled him to win
the Republican nomination and then go on
to the presidency now there have been
bad presidents in American history
they've been even borderline destructive
presidents American history when did you
decide that Trump sort of transcended
this and posed a threat to the American
system of democracy itself
the concern my concern is only
secondarily with Donald Trump mm-hmm it
is with this larger system so what I
became aware concerned by and when I
started writing with us was years before
Donald Trump was even thought of as a
candidate for president
my interest in repressive populism
really intensified in the early part of
the 2000s as I started covering the Tea
Party movement and writing a lot about
that it was plain to me that the
ideological extremism of the regular
Republican Party which was so
plutocratic so indifferent to what
America
is going through the terrible recession
what was happening to middle-class
incomes was happening to middle-class
savings the or the first origins of the
accelerating drug crisis which you could
already see shaping up a decade ago was
opening space for something dangerous
and then you could see this dangerous
thing taking form first in Europe happen
in France and in the countries of
southeastern Europe Hungary and Poland
and I became morbidly obsessed that such
a thing was possible in the United
States that it was coming and I didn't
know it would be Donald Trump in fact I
was I was quite surprised but when he
showed up I realized this is what we've
been waiting for I'm glad you raised
that the there's these two sort of
threads running through the book right
one is about just the stuff that Trump
is doing Yeah right
and you also write though about these
pre-existing vulnerabilities that Trump
sort of very sagely identified and
exploited so when you're you're looking
at the challenges to American democracy
today under the trump presidency you
know how much are you worried about the
man and the family and how much is it
more institutional and systemic when
you're well and healthy you shake off
infections that can kill you if you're
not well and healthy there are
circumstances where a Donald Trump or
somebody like him could have fluked into
office in the way the Donald Trump
fluked into office and then the American
system a healthy American system of
government would stop and let me give
you a very concrete example of what I
mean right now right now Donald Trump is
receiving millions of dollars in
payments from foreign business partners
the Philippines Turkey you know Emirates
India we don't know how much we don't
know whether it's a flat fee or whether
he's getting percentages we have no idea
what we do know is it seems to be
affecting American foreign policy
because the countries that from which he
draws these incomes the Philippines in
Turkey seem to get much easier treatment
from him than the countries from which
he does not the most extreme example
this is in the Persian Gulf where
Bahrain and Saudi Arabia that have been
good business partners to the Trump
family get one treatment and Qatar which
not only didn't have its national day in
the Trump Hotel but which actually
cancelled lease in the Trump Tower in
2014 they they get into it's obviously
affecting American foreign policy you
can imagine in a healthier Society that
Congress would do something about this
now a Jimmy Carter facing all Democratic
Congress Bill Clinton in his first two
years facing all Democratic Congress
they held those presidents accountable
this Congress does not and the
complicity between Trump and the
Republican Congress that's the first
building block no this time policy there
are different schools of thought among
Trump critics about the the threats that
that this this presidency is posing
there are some who worry about the
authoritarian tendencies that are that
are emerging others who see more of sort
of a chaos you know theory that you know
it's amateur hour in in the White House
and then others just worried about the
unpredictability of Trump this is the
Hillary Clinton criticism that you know
if you can bait a man with a tweet etc
you know obviously these things can
overlap but after a year one of Trump is
there is there one of these tendencies
that tends to worry you most Donald
Trump is negligent and indifferent to
everything that a president properly
should do but he's quite active
committed and wily about the things the
president should not do so all there's
truth to all of these points I mean
there is there is chaos because Donald
Trump cannot abide any restraint even
the kind of restraint that is in his own
self-interest automatic example of this
story tell in the book I'd by the way I
want to make them in a safe story these
things are all reported by other people
and I'm very dependent on him grateful
to the reporting of others one things I
tried to do in the book was always to
pay credit not just to the institution
but to the individual reporter although
this has become a challengers one of the
innovations of the Trump years pioneered
by your paper is because the president
denies everything
the paper started quoting 42 sources on
a story that means you get violent not
just the double-barreled vial on which
was a big deal in the past but three
barreled and even four barrel by lines
and that poses a bit of a
The Washington Post thanks you for
giving credit to individual reporters
but they'll be careful do amazing work
so here's the story
so when HR McMaster places Michael Flynn
as national security advisor one of the
first things he sets out to do is to
reaffirm the American commitment to NATO
Trump has made a lot of noises that are
very nervous about how much he dislikes
NATO and of course he's so much under
Russian influence or worse it's a big
problem
so McMaster arranges for Trump to pay a
visit to NATO headquarters in Brussels
he will there he will give a speech
standing in front of the monument to
article 5 a twisted girder from the
World Trade Center and there in front of
that are at NATO headquarters in front
of that monument he will read a
full-throated no compromise commitment
to the mutual defense treaty and to be
sure that Trump says the right things
McMaster writes the passage himself or
at least oversees the writing with a
with a writer and it's in the speech on
the way to Europe McMaster briefs
reporters this is what the president is
going to say Crump gets to that portion
of the speech and he skips the keep ask
me why ideological hostility to NATO
some pressure from the Russians or maybe
he just doesn't like being told what to
do we don't know but that's where you
see the consequence because what then
has to happen of course is McMaster now
is in the situation where everyone
expected this endorsement game and the
question is Wow is the president
reneging is the United States reneging
and McMasters to brief reporters I don't
know what you're talking about the
president did exactly what everybody
expects oh you get the chaos from you
got the necessity to lie even calm the
breaking of the White House staff the
discrediting of McMaster in the eyes of
the perhaps one most honorable soldiers
in this generation so I think these
things come together but I would
emphasize Donald Trump has driven above
all by greed and by the desire for
dominance very little by ideology could
someone else have stepped in to do this
right is is Trump across the only
possible with Donald Trump could someone
else do you think have
you know in in as skillfully a manner
exploited these vulnerabilities that you
identified somebody will and because one
of these we need to address the Western
world we are seeing a global decline in
confidence and democracy belief in
democracy and the effectiveness of
democracy across the Democratic world
and in the United States it happened to
express itself in the more right leaning
party but in other countries it has
expressed itself in the more
left-leaning parties I mean a lot of the
forces behind Donald Trump you see in
Spain and in Greece and parties of the
left in Italy in England in in Britain
in the prime minister in the candidacy
of Jeremy Corbyn leader the Labour Party
and many of the things that worried me
show up inside I mean democratic party
has been a more level-headed party in
recent years in the Republican Party but
one of the themes I stress in the book
that is back of this at the most
fundamental level our racial sexual and
economic tension see and the sexual
tensions I draw a special attention to
if you followed the Bernie Sanders
versus Hillary Clinton primaries the the
gender gap between Sanders voters and
Clinton voters was bigger than the
gender gap in the general election
between Trump supporters and Clinton
supporters and a lot of the things that
were unleashed in social media in that
whereas or more misogynistic than the
themes that were unleashed you have a
lot of disaffected men a lot of isolated
women and that is one of the sources of
energy for these anti-democratic
movements you in the book you spend some
time on the conventional notions of why
Trump did or didn't win in in 2016
you're not entirely persuaded by the the
white working-class theory of the case
for instance what are the things you
think that we least understand about
what propelled him to power first you
have to pay attention more to the
nomination then is that that was the
freakish thing you know once you'll one
of the two most likely people on earth
to be the president the united states i
right right so and and a lot of that was
was a lucky bounce in the in the general
election also the the real question is
not about Donald Trump it's about
Hillary Clinton because Barack Obama in
the fall
2016 was polling well above 50% the
economy was growing personal incomes
were rising political scientists would
tell you the party of the president
should no I don't need doesn't matter
Republican Democrat don't tell me their
names I'm looking at these numbers the
party of the president should win a
third term certainly should cut and and
so when Hillary Clinton got forty eight
point something such a big gap between
her performance and Obama's that's the
first thing that needs to be explained
voter suppression is indeed part of the
story but there's more to it than that
her weakness enabled then Trump's lucky
bounce the aid from the Russians the
Comey thing to have their impact but if
she had been stronger she should have
been able to resist those things but the
battle for the nomination that's that's
the mesmerising miss Trump should not
have won that what ought to have
happened is Jeb Bush campaigned as Paul
Ryan plus more immigration you know the
Republican and so he was set up that
bubble was set up to pop if he went to
these Tea Party rallies you saw what the
Republican base was signaling is we want
more health care less immigration no
more bushes and what they were offered
and said was less health care more
immigration and one more bush so he was
vulnerable the questions why didn't some
more normal political actor Scott
Walker's anything like that who was a
brief very brief frontrunner okay and
yeah and yeah okay not the world's most
charismatic die but he had a story he
had a store it or somebody else why
didn't somebody else into it these
themes that Donald Trump was intuiting
that Republican voters want Medicare
protected not dismantle they want less
immigration not more that they are going
to need their Social Security
why didn't such a person's take those
themes and then deploy them and be the
one to lay Jeb Bush low and that is part
of the part of the story of the
preconditions that enabled Trump is the
ideological rigidity of a Republican
Party that even when the $50 bill is
lying on the sidewalk in front of you
you cannot pick it up because it just
can't be there it's not possible that it
can be there in fact they had written a
whole autopsy report for 2012 explaining
why all of it really
people with one the connection or
another to the jet they read it how
quand dad with Jeb Bush not the fix was
in but but a shrewder political
character should have been able to see
and I this is terrible advice
this putt in this report because of the
report said when I talk I just start the
book by talking about our elf early in
the book of the 2012 election hell
within 72 hours the entire Republican
Party has converged on the message
changed nothing you know ready for Mitt
Romney believe in written Romney I think
it in a fabulous press but the party
sent him took campaign on on a platform
that included gradually withdrawing the
Medicare guarantee from everyone under
55 I mean it's amazing he got 47% of the
vote I think he only got as much as that
because people did not understand what
the Republicans were promising to do to
their own voters you might have thought
that the reaction to after the fort was
and we need to be a little less
dismissive of people who work for wages
we need to be more attentive to the fact
that you even our voters really like
Medicare and want it to be available
even to those who are now under 55 they
couldn't see that they could only see
the part of the Romney platform they did
not like which was his moderate
moderately tough line and immigration
didn't like that less jettison that and
make it a 100 percent rich person
platform it's as you say it's it's easy
to fixate on on Trump right you know the
he's on the title of your book it's the
it's the classic overcoat shot than
people that book publishers love these
days yet you write in the introduction
that this book is not the story of Trump
or not just the story of Trump it's the
story of those who enable empower
support and collaborate with Donald
Trump mm-hmm who are they who are the
enablers how do you break them down
let's start with in concentric circles
first there are those who immediately
serve Him who lie for him and I think I
mean often poor understand we have a
noble reasons like like HR McMaster
lying to conceal the fact the president
United States does not want to honor the
NATO treaty they are the larger
executive branch now outside the White
House
the Department of Justice and the FBI
staff with people who are like rod
Rosenstein puzzle they've never seen Ron
Rosenstein who seems like a
conscientious and not very imaginative
person struggling to do the right thing
while also mollifying the president
trying to walk the fine the line and not
understanding what a spirit of
destruction indicate I mean what he's
negotiating with how implacable so a lot
of people are baffled by this in the
exec you know executive branch the
people in the FBI is well trying you
know to follow their traditional rules
in the face of a president is unlike
anything else then we widen it some more
and it's the Republicans in Congress who
are not doing their job not insisting on
basic things like if the present United
Sates is on the payroll of foreign
businesspeople
the country needs to know about that
then it's the Republican donor Lee that
believed they could use him and didn't
understand that he would use them and in
fact didn't understand that their idea
made them hostages I mean normally what
happens in the first year of a
presidency is the president has an
agenda wants to accomplish things and
he's surrounded by people with human
weaknesses and so he you know you've
seen it it's in the LBJ movies the
president wants a civil rights bill the
member of the House of Representatives
wants a dam and the deal is done this
this is the other way around that Paul
Ryan has the agenda and Donald Trump
wants all that has is the person of all
the human weaknesses that's the they are
the enablers as those donors who believe
that this guy would be the vehicle for
achieving what they wanted and the the
price would be something bearable and
finally the enablers are the is re
there's one more step the enables are
the conservative intellectual world
which developed a series of
rationalizations that in justifications
and excuses if if they can't defend them
they attack his opponents if they can't
convincingly attack his opponents they
change the subject if they can't change
the subject then they just go quiet
altogether and lastly there are in the
country these Americans who are million
they're millions drawn to a radical
politics of authoritarianism
as a way of achieving what things they
want to achieve and then punishing
people who they want to punish there's a
lot to unpack there let's let's let's
start with with the party a little bit
you um you know you you write that you
know once in office it was not Trump's
own cunning that enabled him to defy
long established standards decent
behavior was a complicity of his allies
in the Republican Party and that the
once great party has United to elevate
one man into position about almost
absolute power over itself clearly the
Republican Party the the Department
stablishment thought they were getting
something yes out of this deal what have
they gotten beyond a tax bill out of
this deal they've got in the tax bill
they've gotten substantial
deconstruction of a lot of Obama era
environmental regulations they're
looking forward to more of those as a
Obama left behind because he couldn't
pass legislative restrictions on carbon
emissions he left behind a very
elaborate EPA scheme for regulating
carbon and like EPA's its het it's
intrusive and burdensome and often
irrational and a big project of the
coming year will be shutting that down
they got relief from some of the parts
of Obamacare and some hope that although
Obamacare couldn't be repealed maybe it
could be damaged enough to collapse they
they get important favors for the
financial industry and above all the the
breaking of the consumer plant
protection a Consumer Financial
Protection Board that that has just been
dismantled Donald Trump has his own OMB
director serving at the same time as the
director of the Consumer Protection
Board paralyzing that that body so I
think that yeah I know Gorsuch right
they got they got Neil Gore so that's
probably more important to the
rank-and-file than to the donor elite
but yes happy about that I'm so they
they're getting stuff they're getting
real substantial tangible benefits you
know one of the things that and this
this corporate in control let's not
minimize how big a deal that is one of
the arguments it's long been argued by
economist who
the corporate income tax is it is it
paid by workers is it paid by consumers
or is it paid by shareholders so we we
now have an answer to that question when
the stock market goes up you know 30% on
the expectation of a corporate income
tax cut the stock market is saying we
think the shareholders are getting most
of this because if it were going to
workers and customers then the stock
market shouldn't have reacted to it at
all
you write that Trump has ripped out the
conscience of half of the political
spectrum and left a moral void where
American conservatism once was did Trump
do that or they were so ready when did
that excavation of the moral conscience
of the Republicans begin I mean you've
been an in-house critic of the party for
a while throughout the the Obama years
your former colleague at AEI Norm
Ornstein wrote a book several years ago
about what he viewed as a kind of moral
bankruptcy of the party already when did
this begin the trend begins I think in
reaction to disappointment with the Bush
presidency in which I served against the
reaction gains to the economic
disappointments in the Iraq war which I
was a supporter and the party began to
move in a more radical direction and
when I say radical toward economic
individualism toward a more plutocratic
politics at exactly the same time that
the American middle class from which the
Republican Party had historically drawn
its strength was getting into bigger and
bigger trouble and especially white
America for which the Republican Party
again his disproportion of drawing the
signs was getting into particularly big
trouble with debt diseases and addiction
so that the party had moved away from
its vote voters and that's that that's
the beginning that's the beginning of
rotten and the book opens with a series
of so the steps down which the American
political system is tumbling and again I
although this is primarily a Republican
story I think it's true of both parties
that since the end of the Cold War
they've been paying the playing the
political game much more ruthlessly than
they did between 1945 and 1990 that's
again one of the themes of the book is I
don't think we understood at the time
how much the Cold War limited what the
parties did to each other the
the country was in a deadly lethal the a
lethal great power competition depended
on presidential leadership and so the
president had to be respected president
had to be respectable and the parties
had to set some limits on what they do
to each other in order to ensure that
the president could lead in this deadly
struggle with the struggle behind us the
party competitions become much more
savage and the president has become a
person is much less necessary to respect
and much more just an ordinary party
leader this is the the mutual toleration
norm write the radical scientists talk
exactly between the parties now you
write also that during this first year
of Trump you know so much of the
attention has been on on the president's
you know bullying or raging or his his
tweets and unpredictability but you say
the most radical attack on American
norms of governance in his first year
were attempted by the regular
Republicans in the house and in the
Senate right
what were those most radical attacks
well they undertook to gigantically
expensive pieces of legislation this
huge tax cut and the repeal of Obamacare
and the replacement with a new kind of
medical system details to be filled in
later and they did all of this without
hearings of any kind
and with the costs and benefits produced
at the very last minute in ways that
really were not really we're not well
done um and that was especially true of
the tax bills that to this day no one
knows what the true fiscal cost of this
bill is going to be because the bill
creates so many possibilities for
arbitrage and gamesmanship I mean that
you have to estimate well how many
people really are going to take
advantage of these new paths through
LLC's they're so complicated the regs
haven't been written yet you don't know
the answer to that question so you don't
know how much individual income tax
you're gonna lose from high-income
taxpayers but so the country was invited
to buy a pig in the poke twice without
hearings without anyone without anyone
without opponents of the legislation
getting a chance to be heard to be heard
and present expert witnesses of what
this would mean that's a real departure
big big pieces of legislation I mean
again we've been getting hay steer
Obamacare passed more hastily than major
pieces of legislation in the past but
you know Obamacare was the
in a model of legislative procedure
compared to what happened after 2017 I
want to talk a little about the the
people around Trump in the
administration and and in the White
House you know there were those very
early on who signed public letters
stating their opposition to Trump in the
in the especially than in the national
security realm and they were the true
believers who were with Trump from the
beginning and then you've had those who
have sort of made their peace about
serving in this White House or this
administration perhaps even as an effort
to protect against the excesses of of
the president you talked about them in
the book you say that when good people
do bad things they usually have good
reasons what role do these people play
in Trump Accorsi I'm talking about
people like HR McMaster like like Jim
mattis will we look back on them as as
enablers or as like a last line of
defense well for many of the situation
would be quite tragic so Jim mattis has
the advantage he's across the river yes
he's in a giant bureaucracy that has
tremendous power of its own and he's a
four-star general McMaster is just a
three-star which you or me doesn't mean
much but within their universe that is
an overwhelming difference he's a man at
the end of his career with nothing more
that he needs to accomplish how the
Madison Madison yeah and in fact is
sacrificing you know the the he's
sacrificing the rewards a peaceful life
with his family and friends that he has
abundantly earned in order to be there
he also knows that he cannot be part but
that would that would just that would be
a conflagration if he were fired and if
fired
he can't be replaced because the
replacement would have to go through a
Senate confirmation hearing so somebody
like that can be a real check and I
think mattis has been to the point where
mattis has actually been able to in
various ways make clear how little
regard yeah as for Donald Trump I mean
at that North the transgender ban for
instance George I've been at the North
Korea rumor that North Korea and a base
self-abasement session as a session so
what watch it mattis mattis he doesn't
he doesn't do it he has this this came
into the public domain by accident that
speech he gave to soldiers in Jordan
where he's talking to a group of a
couple of dozen soldiers
somebody videos have been posted on
YouTube in which he begins by saying I
don't have to tell you my fine young
soldiers sailors airmen and Marines that
our country isn't what it should be
right now that the days we have to get
back to being more respectful to one
another kinder to one another and until
that happens I'm asking you just to hold
the line so that's a pretty serious and
it sounds like the description of what
he's doing it sounds like what is doing
other but other people have less
immunity there you know it is one if
you're on the same side of the river as
the president if you're in the same
building as the president if you're
fireable by the president if your
successor does not need to be Senate
confirmed and if you want things from
the president that alters it so I quote
in the book exchange I had with my good
friend Elliot Cohen who went through a
lot it was a great military expert great
expert on national defense and he went
through a lot of wrestling with himself
about the advice to give friends and at
first he said you should serve and then
later he changed his mind and when I in
this dialogue with him so that okay my
advice Alaska's question was you to
those considering this you need to
consider the role whether you're
directly serving the President or
whether you're serving the national
security and then you need to know
yourself and to know what how sure am i
that you've asked to do something wrong
I will say no and the final reflection
is and once you're sure that you will do
the right thing consider this if the
president agreed with you would you have
given you the job in the first place I
guess it's too early perhaps to discern
and what what buckets are what
categories some of that's different or
disappoints it's all in we can see that
the outstanding bad actors we can
already see them we can see some of the
good actors and then it's complicated
some people are good in some ways and
bad in other ways like Rex Tillerson is
proven I think to be a disastrous
Secretary of State but but he's also
proving to be a non enabler of Donald
Trump that he is and so that's that's a
complicated verdict mm-hmm there's also
a risk another risk you identify to this
role
right you you warned in the book that
trumps disregard for long-held norms of
democratic behavior may pressure others
to in turn disregard their own long-held
norms of behavior in particularly you
worry that the military whether it's
active-duty generals retired generals
who are serving the administration could
be tempted to expand their role and to
be less deferential yes to civilian
control do you see do you still worry
about that you see any signs of that
materializing thank you for bringing
this up this is one of the most this is
I think one of things that worries me
most it's not tended to get as much
discussions other things in the book I
call this the auto immune disorders of
krump the system in self-defense does
things that are bad I mean I might joke
with this it's seven days in May only
what the generals is the good guys so so
I've seen that I've seen that movie
that's obviously if Jett if Jim mattis
were president right now I think the
whole country would be happier but the
fact is Jim mattis is not present he's
in the chain of command he has to
execute the president's orders and if
the way the country is going to protect
itself from Donald Trump is by military
escaping civilian control that's very
dangerous and it's happening in lots of
ways that one senses but we can't be
sure for example President rompers
allows 14 people to read the president's
daily intelligence briefing instructions
allow three four five six them you know
normally be the vice president National
Security Advisor the chief of staff
basically that's it Bill Clinton let
Hillary Clinton read it but it's
basically the bat and that group of
people and that's a few enough people
and high enough people really be able to
hold important secrets trumpets 14
people including his highly ethically
compromised son-in-law read it and we
and of course we know about his blurting
crucial secrets to the Russian
ambassador's either because he wants
just to show off or some for some more
sinister reason so if you're the people
in charge of these secrets and you know
the president isn't very curious he gets
most of his news from Fox and Friends
anyway how informative I
it's the president's Daily Brief today
compared to what it was like two years
ago or eight years ago information
begins to stop flowing and maybe you get
from sort of a wink and a nod permission
from the McMaster you're not helped
Brett tell the president if the
obviously we ask you a question you
can't lie they never ask questions just
anything sensitive leave it out and and
what we see is you know the generals
getting in the getting a lot of
operational authority remember the
mother of all bombs that Giants the
president was very proud to tell us the
theater commander made that decision all
by himself
well theater camp commanders are getting
into the habit of making a lot of
decisions all by themselves it's hard to
undo those habits I told you those
happens especially if you consider what
is happening to the Democratic Party
that it might be if you have four years
of Donald Trump and then Donald Trump is
replaced by some George HW Bush figure
widely respected in the national
security bureaucracy and very well
informed about the national he made that
next president he or she may be able to
pull the authority the president back
together but what if that next person is
as much an outlier on the Democratic
side as Donald Trump is on the
Republican side what is wrong Trump has
two terms bureaucracies always want to
slip the leash military bureaucracies
always mistrust civilians remember chief
of staff John Kelly's outburst about his
contempt real contempt for civilian
Authority if you have not served you
have no right to ask me questions yeah I
mean could there be a more unamerican
sentence than that you know that's
exactly who has the right guys the
questions your civilian masters for whom
you work you you've said and right now I
don't recall if this is in an interview
or or in the book that when when when
Trump first came along you you described
yourself as sort of vaguely Trump
curious yes right you felt that he could
sort of shake up and what had become a
very high down party you didn't think he
would win yeah right but you thought he
could be salutary right for the
Republican Party to to rethink some of
its some of its you know policies and
and
and and verities now that you've seen
sort of the symbiosis between Donald
Trump and the Republican Party what
happens to this party after Trump it has
three futures at least I can see three
future paths for and they'll depend on
events the best-case scenario is it
there is a decisive electoral lesson at
at the same time as local electorates
reject the attempt to make voting more
difficult that we're seeing spreading
across so much of the country there is a
sharp lesson and a sharp lesson that non
democratic methods are not going to be
acceptable and the party then evolves to
be a more normal right-of-center
party of enterprise and business like
the British conservatives the Canadian
conservatives the German Christian
Democrats parties you see all over of
the Australian Liberals that says you
know we're gonna we accept the rules of
the game we accept the social insurance
state as was built in the thirty years
after World War two and within that
context we're speaking up for people you
know savers and people on businesses and
private sector people and the not
because the others are illegitimate or
not American but because they've got a
party of theirs and then because a lot
of what democracy is about is there some
questions where you do want you have to
do it one way or the other and the way
you do it is by putting up hands and
taking a towel whatever eyes the more
hands gets to do what his or her way um
that's the most optimistic scenario it's
also possible though the party remains
wedded to the plutocratic agenda of the
Ryan years and the defeats aren't so bad
and this the Trump solution looks
workable the disenfranchised solution
looks like it's workable and I mean like
voter suppression or suppression you
know one of the things one of the things
I when I wrote this book I want it is
there some people I was in dialog with
or argument with one of the things I was
arguing against when Donald Trump was
elected sworn in there's a great spasm
of oh my god this is like January 1933
in Germany
and when I watched us that's not what
modern authoritarianism is good you
can't look at the most spectacular most
hideous case of democratic breakdown in
all of political history in the most
extreme circumstances of hyperinflation
and unemployment and famine and near
civil war say that's me yes that's us
that's not that's not how it's gonna
happen that the whole point to modern
authoritarianism where you see in the
Philippines in South Africa in India is
this it's much more economical that you
know you can get do judge if you can
identify the right six percent of the
population and stop them from voting
that's just as good or better than can't
swing the election all together yet you
get just as much power and with a lot
less squawking and the end the
legitimacy yeah imma see so just and you
don't and it turns out you don't have to
disqualify very many people and you
don't even have to tell anybody you have
to tell yourself what you're doing you
do what they're telling yourself there's
a book out it's same time as yours and I
think of it as sort of in dialogue with
your book it's called how democracies
die yes Stephen Levitsky and Daniel's a
black and they they they discussed that
and they they basically say the most
likely scenario is that think of the
United States like it all becomes kind
of North Carolina yes right where you've
seen a lot of moves toward this kind of
behavior yes the you know how how sort
of simpatico do you think the the the
GOP is to that kind of scenario I think
I think that is a very possible scenario
zib let's previous book it was a huge
influence on my thinking and this and I
I'm gonna recommend it to real hardcore
history people because for it it is a
toothy tooth e-book but his his central
thesis in that book he compares the
comparison of European democracies in
the 19th century is it a lot of the
success of democracy and civil that
speaks here as a man of the left is
their ability to reassure holders of
wealth and power that democracy will not
be too much of a threat to their
interests that if you have too radical
democracy and this this is
something I say in the book is that I
quote this saying you've seen it on the
internet your uncle's probably send it
to you but a democracy can only last
until the majority learns it can fold
itself benefits from the public treasury
Don Trump jr. sent this round this this
sentiment is attributed to a lot of
people Alexis de Tocqueville sometimes
Aristotle other times some Scottish
astray it seems as best as anybody can
it can tell to have been come from an
op-ed in The Daily Oklahoman in the
1950s by by retired state legislator but
wherever it comes from it's the opposite
of the truth that where democracy's get
into trouble and as leaving aside the
extreme scenarios of the 1930s is when
people who possess assets become
convinced that letting everybody vote
means they will lose those assets and
the way where democracy survives is our
people of assets become become convinced
that the small price that they will have
to pay to keep their assets is worth it
because the better the greater stability
of a democratic system and what is
happening the United States right now is
that asset holders have are freaked out
Obama freaked that the depression for
the recession freaked them out Obama
freaked them out they thought my god you
know this Kenyan Muslim is going to take
everything from me and leave me just
like a few hundred billion dollars you
know to rub together in my pants and in
order to defend what they had they
became open to more radical solutions
you in your concentric circles of the
enablers he talked about sort of
conservative intellectuals who who kind
of accommodated themselves to to trump
what has the rise Donald Trump done to
conservative thought there's a recent
essay in The Washington Post magazine
that says that there's this kind of
revitalization of of conservative
publications
yeah and that um in periods of
alienation from power are when creative
political thought seems to thrive do you
see that happening among perhaps the the
the conservative intellectuals who have
not made their peace with Donald Trump I
think that could happen I hope it will I
don't see any sign that it's happened
yet what in because we're still at the
point where people are being given the
moral acid test and I am impressed and
grateful at how many people are and
including some people I wouldn't have
expected they are our sort of shining in
this moment and are standing up so
that's that's exciting others less so
and I'm I referenced in the book the
famous never Trump issue of national
interview two dozen people signed it but
about half of those two dozen people
have made their explicit peace with
Donald Trump and in some cases quite
object so brent bozell the media
Research Center who went from signing
that issue to be one of trumps most
ferocious defenders and one of the
fiercest critics of those conservatives
who do not go along with all Trump but
who were where he was at the time of the
election but the intellectual project no
deed I don't see any signs of vitality
there and partly because I don't think
American service yet understand how
out-of-date their ideas are how much
they were solutions to problems from one
period of history one set of
circumstances now radically those
conditions have changed I'm looking for
this would be very concretely I'm not
this is my life story and I'm not I
apply this to myself as much as others
so the conservatives and I grew up in
the 1970s and 80s if you have an
inflation we know just what to do in the
liberal say it's wage and price controls
we know its monetary restraint and
deregulation we know what to do if you
have a challenge from a totalitarian
ideological geopolitical enemy we know
what to do if you have a lot of crime we
know what to do but even if you have
deflation and economic stagnation if you
have international chaos in the
breakdown of the us-led International
order if you have a drug epidemic and
not a crime epidemic then we're a little
baffled and so we respond to all this by
insisting that America suffers from the
problems we do know how to solve and
does not suffer from the problems we do
not know how to solve and the real
revitalization of concern begins when
conservatives can acknowledge new
problems
I'd say we're that
that certain principles and values may
endure but your policy you can't
fetishize policy solutions and that work
is all I I don't see that work being
done but I want to patreon to say that
in the context of paying tribute to the
character the people are quoted in that
Washington Post article and I think
they've shown themselves people
character and that should that that
should always be hailed and saluted
there's a past that you have in the book
that I wanted to ask you about because I
wasn't entirely clear where it was
headed and you say maybe you don't care
about the future of the publican party
but you should conservatives will always
be with us if conservatives become
convinced they cannot when
democratically they will not abandon
conservatism they will reject democracy
yes what does that mean well that's what
we're just talking about a minute ago
that the greater North Carolina that
they will become that you will see is
more and more people saying explicitly
what more many Republican members of the
House have said which is I don't think
everybody should vote
I think voting wheat voting should be
difficult you should have to make an
effort you shouldn't be able to just it
shouldn't be just anybody walking in off
the street I mean the theory of
democracy you know the is most pungently
expressed in a series of debates during
English Civil War 400 years ago which is
the poorest he has a light has a life to
live just as much as the greatest tea
and that's the idea of democracy is you
know not ever people are not equal in
wisdom or aptitude or wealth but from
the point of view of the meaning of
their own lives their human worth they
are all equal you know in that respect
we are all one one one one and the
democratic theory says that that one
voice for that one person about his or
her own life is entitled to equal
consideration if you start saying well
but not if they're late not if we're not
if they can't get off work on a Tuesday
then they're you're discarding them and
and then you can build a lot of
rationalizations as to as to why it's so
and look and some of the
rationalizations actually may have a lot
of power
behind that there may be you know I
think there are you know there there's
something we said for not letting people
about six months before loading day
they'll be deprived of information they
need at some level you know that we
can't run this it's it's not a it's not
a 24-hour drugstore and and there's
something to be and I voting from home
you know you ought there's something to
be said for participating in collective
civic rituals and going to a place to
cast the votes many of these things can
be defended but there's this mood that
says we want to actually stop certain
categories of people and that is driven
by the anxieties of people if things to
protect but isn't that at some level of
rejection of conservatism 'he's belief
in individual liberty and
self-determination well yes with
individual conservatives and believes in
in those things and and that's why
conservatives one has been able to make
its its peace with democracy and that's
an historical fact to i mean that many
democratic innovations were driven by
conservative minded people you know what
sometimes in ways that's uncomfortable
for modern people to confront I mean how
how much of the energy behind women's
suffrage was was conservative that one
one of the things that advocates of
women's suffrage counted on women voters
to do was to suppress strikes
out-of-control drinking that that
women's that the the big Arthur there's
is not it's not a coincidence that what
American women got the vote at exactly
the same time not just after the first
world war in the country is cracking
down on all kinds of other forms of
behavior especially labor radicalism and
an alcohol dependency and the women were
mobilized because it was thought they
would they would vote for a more orderly
kind of society and indeed the huge
Republican landslide of 1920 was enabled
by the fact by the hugely disre port by
the gender gap in the Republican favored
by Women Voters you write in the book
about Trump's response to the
demonstrations and counter
demonstrations in violence in shock
it's Phillip Virginia and they're
clearly appear to be white nationalist
forces that feel emboldened and and take
comfort in in Donald Trump's rise it's
not it's not a huge focus of the book
but more broadly what do you see is the
role of the alt-right in the Trump
presidency and Beyond it do you think
Trump has unleashed something that he
really doesn't quite control or
understand I think that's a good way to
put it yes when you get radical
movements they you have to is this
radical movement something that's so
marginal that you don't need to deal
with it the Symbionese Liberation Army
in the 1970s you know certain extreme
animal rights activist groups that you
know these are people they do violent
things and then the answer is well you
just tried crack crack them down there
won't be more than 40 of them arrest
them for their crimes remove them from
society society will be safe but
sometimes you get radical groups that
are expressing something real broadly
shared the black panthers that when the
black planters were violent criminals
but they were in radicalized form
speaking to something power that black
america was not content with the
achievements of the first wave of the
civil with a rim that in fact this had
opened the way to a lot of anger and you
know okay we can vote but we want an
equal share of the society at that point
what wisely stable policy what a wise
conservatism does is to say
confronting someone like the background
is what we have to do is we have to
identify the antisocial personalities
here and isolate marginalism and then we
have to identify the grievances they're
exploiting and we have to address and
it's a combination of both repression
and concession that's how you meet
radical groups that are broadly based
and that's I think my reaction to things
like like Charlottesville and one of the
reasons why I was trump curious but end
of the same time so Trump horrified I
mean the alt-right or whatever you want
to call that it's made up of obviously
many violent socio and Psychopaths cruel
and vicious people but it's also
channeling that something is gone very
wrong
less educated part of white America and
that people are killing themselves with
drugs with America's the lowest seatbelt
use of any developed country why we're
less likely to put children in car seats
in any other developed country why is
there something we're not finding life
precious enough the addiction the but
the the self-medication with with with
food and and and video games and i would
say i get in trouble this with the rise
in use of marijuana which is I think
doubled since 2007 something's going
wrong so and and those people end up
sometimes in the other sometimes they
end up dropping out of society
altogether so the task of creative
leadership and this is one the reason
why when I speak to my friends on the
right way done I see Donald Trump is
such a tragedy why you can't say well
there's good and bad he's achieved
things for what he's doing is he's
taking everything that you ought to be
working on and he's corrupted it and
putting it to a dead end what the
response to the alt-right is yeah I mean
the I the ones who bear arms president
the ones who incite you know the on the
internet who basically play the part of
self radicalizing jihadi preachers you
know marginalize them but those millions
of under 30 young men who are earning
less than women don't see marriage in
their future are experimenting with
drugs and are putting themselves on the
path to a self-destructive and socially
harmful life maybe they need a bigger
answer than being told that they should
be ashamed of how much privilege they
got you I want to I want to shift a
little bit to the international scene
one of your big concerns in this book is
that Trump is eroding America's
leadership in in the world and I know
it's it's hard to to separate these
things but when you think what what part
of Donald Trump's impact do you think
will be more lasting his impact on
American democracy at home or this
erosion of global leadership that is
that that you know that you conical in
champaka see the erosion of local
leadership will certainly be faster to
go into a fact it's already happened I
mean just think if you were
if you're South Korean and how can you
trust the United States that the press
the United States is clearly
contemplating a future in which he
trades hundreds of thousands of
casualties in your country in order to
avoid any nuclear risk to his country at
the same time as he's reneging on deals
like how you pay for the missile defense
of South Korea and as he's attacking the
u.s. South Korea free trade agreement
which is so essential to your country's
prosperity meanwhile he tweets out but
once a month that if you want protection
from a North Korean nuclear missile the
person to ask for that protection from
is the president of China so South Korea
and China they were in the Korean people
and China they've a history of cut
nationalist conflict and obviously ones
that you know democracy and one is not
but if you need security and the Chinese
can provide it and the United States
can't or won't then you'll have to talk
to China with you like it or not I think
that's already in place I think that the
opening of the border between South
Korea North Korea which Donald Trump
hails as an achievement is actually a
vote against his leadership that the
South Koreans are thinking we have to
make our own deal here because the
American guarantee is not trustworthy
and not safe I think you see a lot of
this happening in the continent of
Europe where the United States is the
most important thing that has happened
in Europe since the adoption of the euro
maybe more important than that which is
negotiating an amicable and stable
brexit that's this is a wall and Trump
for some reason that Trump has decided
he said Germany is America's most
important geopolitical enemy and he
could not be more hostile
there isn't a US ambassador to Berlin
and the person he's appointed as his
nominee is an almost deliberate insult
to the German leadership
there's no Mewis ambassador to the to
Brussels to the European Union
headquarters either and trumpet regulars
has something dis obliging to say about
Germany and about the EU that they're
not going to forget this the biggest
jump in math is the jump from zero to
one from non existence to existence and
all of these doubts have jumped into
existence what will it take for the rest
of the world to look to America for
leadership in the way that perhaps it
instead well this this was going to be a
problem for the United States no matter
what the United States half 50% of world
economy in 1945 thirty percent of world
economy in the Nixon years a little over
twenty percent in the Reagan years is on
its way to being about fifteen percent
of the world economy and the United
States has been reinforced by the well
friends but it was if it wanted to exert
the kind of power it did in the 1980s it
was going to need to head a big and
sustained coalition and that's always
difficult so maintaining American
leadership was going to be a difficult
from project no matter what so what it
will take the first enormous economic
growth in the United States would help
making the United States a bigger share
of the world economy bad behavior from
America's rivals will help I mean but
that right now China looks to many like
not an attractive alternative but a more
predictable alternative in the United
States if China behaves in a way that's
unpredictable that may bring some
friends back if you but it will take
barring those things a generation of
careful painstaking tedious work on
institutions that were destroyed by
people who didn't understand how they
worked or why they'd been built the
origins of this book in part are found
in this terrific Atlantic cover piece
you did a year ago something along the
lines of you know had to build an
autocracy right the timing of that was
extraordinary by the way I think your
editors posted it just as the as the
travel ban was the first Taliban was
going in Jeff Goldberg's genius was
supposed to come out a week later and
Jeff Goldberg's our new editor and he's
just one of these people with this like
preternatural sense for where the public
is and and by the way this was a costly
decision because these cover stories are
linked to print advertising and he bit
the bullet to say this was an economic
risk to release it early on the internet
because this was the moment and he was
come as usual completely right but the
fact Jeff is so often completely right
that you forget how unusual it is
to be out right so often but he is there
that was completely right the induct
piece you you put yourself four years
into the future imagining the beginning
of a second
Trump term and a lot of the things you
you thought that you know what would be
characterizing them characterizing the
country at the time you know are things
like a a sort of compliant GOP Congress
a sort of stigmatized press a kind of
like wearily quiescent public eye I'd
like to ask you to cast forward again
now sort of one year in to the Trump
presidency based on what you see and
this this this conflict this fight that
you identify between Trump ROC and
American democracy traditionally defined
you know do you see the guardrails
holding how do you see this battle
playing out I think many of the things I
envisioned being true in 2021 did come
are in the process of coming true so the
fundamentals but the trouble years were
prosperous that he was here antic
deficits he had lose money he had
immigration restriction policies that
tighten the labor market and he spent a
lot on infrastructure the infrastructure
program hasn't materialized yet but it's
not hard to imagine that that it will
and that these things then tighten the
labor market especially for blue collar
blue collar men and that people liked it
I and one of my predictions is at one
twenty eighteen may be a better year for
Donald Trump the 2017 as wage increases
flow through the economy um I did
predict a compliant Congress that
depends on outcomes of elections in 2018
and he may have a very frisky Congress
but if the if the economy is strong in
2018 and wages rise Republican losses
may be less dramatic than most people
today are imagining they will be the
cowing of the the treatment of the press
I spend a lot of time on Trump's use in
that article on Trump's use of antitrust
as a weapon against the press and that's
clearly as you know at the Washington
Post that is clearly a top-of-mind
concern for the president as as has been
the use of the Time Warner merger
pressure on CNN and so far the elite
press has been really resistant and the
Washington Post has played an incredible
role but the larger concern which is
that the article invasion of the press
is it might be that even the elite press
holes but that it's made ever less
relevant by a cut in a country where
more and more people get soft news via
social media and Facebook is making
decisions right now that indicate oh
great willingness to play ball with
authoritarian regimes outside the United
States and that that sort of augers ill
for what it would do if they were under
pressure in the United States you know
Facebook runs a business model that is
tremendously sensitive to government
pressure a very few regulatory
businessman changes could I mean if the
government were just to deem Facebook a
publisher response to so if somebody
somebody defame somebody on Facebook
somebody writes an article in Washington
Post that defame somebody The Washington
Post is liable somebody writes that
article on Facebook the face face book
it's not liable why should that be I
need to make a pretty strong can maybe
Facebook should be liable
maybe maybe Facebook and if Facebook is
liable then suddenly the number of
Facebook's tiny number of employees will
have to they'll have to have editors a
lot to have and then with editors there
vanishes Facebook's enormous
profitability and tiny changes like a
little changes in privacy regulations
Unites States were to adopt EU style
privacy regulations they'll have a huge
impact on Facebook's bottom line it's
easy to imagine pressures like that
being brought brought to bear especially
as we get closer to the next
presidential election David Fromm